hello everyone and welcome to the
precision medicine virtual event my name
is matthew Bainbridge I'm the associate
director of clinical genomics at Rady
Children's Institute for genomic
medicine and I'll be presenting on
precision pediatric genomic medicine
please feel free to submit any questions
during my presentation and I'll follow
you up with you via email so I think the
first question that we really have to
answer is what is precision genomic
medicine and I have a nice short video
to help demonstrate that so if we can
just play the first video please this
little girl is one year old
a one-year-old should be able to sit up
unaided should be able to walk and
certainly should be able to reach for a
toy but this little girl cannot she can
follow the toy with her eyes you can see
she can move her mouth but she can't
reach for it she's effectively paralyzed
you
so this little girl came into our
neurology clinic and we sequenced her
and in three days we got a provisional
diagnosis and what we actually found
were viola luck mutations in a gene
called th so what does tyrosine
hydroxylase do well it takes tyrosine
hydroxylase of it and turns it into
l-dopa and l-dopa is then turned into
dough from you and if you don't have any
th you can't make l-dopa and you can't
make dopamine and dopamine is an
extremely important neurotransmitter so
this girl just could not make this
neurotransmitter and this is what's
cause of her symptoms very fortunately
we can artificially synthesized l-dopa
and we can give l dopa to her as a pill
and that allows her to actually bypass
the block at a tyrosine hydroxylase and
produce your own dopamine and so here
you can see in this next video what it
looks like after she's been on l-dopa
treatment for about four months so here
we have that same little girl and this
is after four months of treatment you
can clearly see that she's sitting up
very well you can see that there's still
a little bit of deviation in her ankles
but she can grab toys and move around
unaided and hold her head unaided after
just four months of treatment that's dad
there dad got dad to lay her down see if
she can get up and she can get up just
fine that's big sister so she can get up
fine on her own she can reach for toys
okay now we're gonna get dad to lay her
down on her front and he can see she
actually has so much strengths you can
really resist being laid down on her
front and she can easily hold herself up
this girl basically went from being
paralyzed to being almost fully
functional in four months
that video is about a year old now if
you saw that girl walking down the
street you would not know anything was
wrong with her um she's she's perfectly
fine she can run she can walk if she's
gonna develop normally and live a happy
healthy life and this is really what we
mean by precision metagenomic medicine
is that we go in we sequence these kids
we figure out exactly what's wrong with
them and then we have an important and
efficacious treatment that can make
their lives better so this is what the
current state of the art looks like in
the ICU children's ICU about five
percent of the kids come in with an
unknown disease etiology and we can
actually sequence them in sort of one to
two days and while what they're getting
that sequencing they get interim
empirical treatment we make a diagnosis
in twenty to forty six percent of cases
depending on the cohort and of those
about thirty one percent overall can
have some sort of change in management
and then 21 percent overall have a
change in outcome there are three very
important steps to actually making this
work
the first is speed it's very important
that we can get these diagnosis and
treatments to these kids in a timely
fashion while there's still some chance
to actually make your lives better
the second is accuracy and by this we
mean we need to know actually that the
diagnosis they get is correct that when
we call the mutation pathogenic it is
pathogenic and the last thing of course
is treatment there's no point in being
able to do all of this if we can't
actually make some change to the child's
health so I'll be talking about these
three factors and what we're doing at
Rady Children's to influence them the
first thing I'll talk to you about is
speed speed is extremely important for
acutely ill children a non rapid
diagnosis is clinically irrelevant for
them we need to be able to treat these
diseases and we need to be able to treat
them early realistically we can deliver
this now in one to three days but
ideally we'd be able to actually return
this in less than eight hours so that a
child would be admitted and during the
same shift we'd actually have a genomic
diagnosis for them realistically this is
only possible by basically pre
sequencing all children at birth it
would be like doing it as a newborn
screen and then we could just do
analysis after those kids are entered
into the neck.you this is a handful of
the kids that we've made diagnoses on at
the Institute all of these diagnoses
have an effective treatment some of them
are very expensive that like gene
therapy some are very inexpensive like
getting vitamin b6 supplementation or
getting galactose what you can see is
that all the kids at the top all those
kids that we sequence later in life I've
either died or being neurologically
devastated by their disease whereas
generally if we can sequence those kids
below 4 months of age or preferably
before a week of age they actually do
well and develop normally about a year
ago we sequence the 19-hour genomes that
means we went from a blood spot to a
diagnosis in 19 hours so this is just
regular for us now just to be able to
turn out a genome that quickly I'm
actually going to concentrate primarily
on the bioinformatics steps after the
initial sequencing because that's where
our focus is being for the last year so
a standard diagnostic interpretation can
take anywhere from you know a day to two
it takes about 18 hours for us to
produce all 125 billion bases of
sequencing data and it takes about an
hour for us to align that data to the
genome and then call the variants what
can be really time-consuming and very
manual is doing the interpretation of
that data and that can take anywhere
from 7 to 12 hours because really what
we need to do is we need to whittle down
those thousands and thousands of
variants to the one or two that are
actually causative one of the key things
and being able to do this is being able
to prioritize those variants based on
the disease phenotype and the way we do
that is that we gather what are called
hpo terms so this is the human phenotype
ontology and this is a set of
standardized terms as well as their
relationship to other terms that also
describe phenotypes so a cardiac
phenotype might be subdivided into very
specific kinds of cardiac phenotypes and
this allows you to do fuzzy matching so
you don't have to perfectly put in
a phenotype for a child you can put in
something that is approximately correct
and we can then figure out how to use
that data usefully through fuzzy
matching and really what we try to do is
that we take the ontology terms for
every disease and we compare it to the
ontology terms that the child has and we
do an overlap a fuzzy fuzzy matching and
get a score to say how much this child
resembles a particular disease and this
then allows us to rank the variants that
the child has based on their phenotypic
overlap to known diseases part of the
difficulty in doing this though and
that's a very quick process and it's
very well-established but part of the
difficulty is actually pulling that data
out of the EMR so an EMR for cutely
children they're usually smaller but for
some of our chronic children you can see
hundreds and hundreds of documents and
sometimes very important phenotypes can
be buried in the EMR they're lost so the
child could have had a MRI when used to
and the results from that MRI may not be
continued on in the EMR so you may not
pick it up by just looking at sort of
the last couple of weeks of EMR data so
we worked with a company called alexion
to generate a program called clinic
think and clean thing goes into the EMR
and extracts hpo terms using natural
language processing a process that could
take 30 minutes to several hours can be
accomplished in about 20 seconds
including you think actually is very
very good at pulling out meaningful
terms and generating good hpo terms from
the EMR using that data we can then like
I said earlier overlap the child's
phenotypes to the known phenotypes are
caused by disease mutations and that
allows us really to sort of whittle down
from you know a million mutations down
to the one causative mutation in about
five minutes the next thing I want to
talk to you about is accuracy and
accuracy can mean a lot of different
things to different people but really
what I'm interested in is when we call
something pathogenic or when we call
something benign are we actually correct
and this is really highlighted by what
we called the variant of unknowns
against problem with a vast problem
buses are when we don't know variant is
pathogenic or not they're a real problem
because they actually impede a child
from getting a diagnosis generally
clinicians will almost always treat this
as benign and basically continue the
search for to get an actual diagnosis
interestingly enough it does not affect
all genes equally so a SXL three which
is on the left there this gene its
dominant it's caused only by de novo
mutations
it's very severe it has high penetrance
high severity and consequently we're
very good at knowing whether the
mutations in this gene are pathogenic or
likely pathogenic when you take a gene
like KC and q2 it can be inherited it
has variable penetrants and so we're
less sure necessarily whether we can
call variant pathogenic or likely
pathogenic r why are two causes a
arrhythmias it can be inherited it has
variable penetrants it has variable
expressivity and it's also a very very
large gene and as subsequently over half
the mutations in clinvar or v you asses
for ry heart too so how can you resolve
a V us well if you see the same variant
over and over again and independent
families and they all have the disease
and the variants rare so we don't see it
in lots of unaffected individual we can
probably implicate it as being
pathogenic the other thing you can do is
they can do experimentation a model
system and there's tons of animal models
like mice fish frog flies chickens and
they're great because they can actually
Fino copy the the disease so if you have
a child with seizures and you put the
mutation into a mouse the mouse might
have seizures as well you can also get
multiple phenotype readouts which is can
be really advantageous so a mouse might
have seizures but they also might have
impaired balance and movement they might
act strangely in an open field test
there's lots of things you can measure
when you're looking at an animal model
system and once you have them generated
they tend to be fairly easy to maintain
on the con size that they can be
expensive to generate sort of five to
fifteen thousand dollars and more
importantly to us it could be very
time-consuming to generate these so it
can take six months even to make a
model 18 months plus to make a good
mouse model when we compare this to a
clinical turnaround time of three days
that's really not acceptable because the
research turnaround time can be months
and months to years and years and it can
actually be so long that result may
never actually get back to the patient
because the patient has moved on and
gone to a different provider you can use
things like cellular model systems which
are single cells or sometimes organoids
they're faster to do they're less
expensive and tend to be easier to
manipulate genetically however they can
be difficult to maintain and generally
you can only really pull out a cellular
phenotype so on the left here that's a
patch clamp so we're looking at the
electric potential across the membrane
of that cell and and that's that can be
fine for a lot of phenotypes but
sometimes it's not and sometimes it
actually does not replicate what we see
in the clinic that is it doesn't look
pathogenic when you're just measuring
the cellular potentials but it is
pathogenic because the children actually
get sick I'm going to talk about worm as
a model system so this is C elegans it's
a small one millimeter in vertebrate
multicellular organism it has some the
best understood neuronal development of
any organism it's an inexpensive model
system and we'd like it because it's a
compromise between complex expensive
mouse models and inexpensive cellular
models and so it still has some some
features of both and this is a
collaboration that we're doing with Lima
metrics which is a company in Eugene
Oregon it's worth taking a moment to
talk about FINA logs and phenol copying
generally as we get more and more
distant from humans as a model system
we're less able to perfectly replicate
the phenotype so on the right there is a
fish and on the top that is a control
fish on the bottom that is a fish with a
cardiac defect and this cardiac defect
rather than measuring say ejection
fraction or the thickness of the cardiac
wall which we would in patients what
we're doing is that we're really just
looking at the edema as a readout so
that's the swelling that you can see
there indicated by the arrow
even when you have mouse models if they
may not actually be able to replicate
the phenotype that you see in the
patient so those are three common
diseases that are well understood and
when you knock the equivalent gene out
in the mouse the mouse actually doesn't
get sick but you can read other readings
to actually see whether those mutations
are pathogenic or not and so what we
talk about when we're looking at
something else rather than a phenol copy
is what we call a fetal log so it's a an
equivalent or a proxy for a clinical
phenotype worms don't have brains or
hearts so we have to look for phenol
logs and something else and as it turns
out the pathologist genes that we have
in our brains in our hearts are actually
expressed in the mouth and GI tract of
the worm in fact 50% of human genes have
a good worm ortholog but actually 70% of
the human disease genes have a good worm
earth log and this really speaks to how
important conservation is to disease
genes or vice versa
even if you do find a good modeling
target so even if there is an ortholog
you may not actually have sequence
conservation so that's another thing to
worry about especially when you're
really interested in inserting review
asses into these genes because you need
to have actually perfect sequence
conservation and the way we get around
that is by humanizing the worm once you
have your target gene what you do is
that you actually just directly
synthesize the cDNA the human cDNA and
then you add to it on either side the
flanking gene regions of the worm
ortholog and you insert this in a
plasmid and the reason why you do this
is because when the plasmid can then
recombine with the worm and it actually
knocks out the worm gene and replaces it
with the human gene and this is
advantageous because this gene this
human gene is actually under control the
same genetic controls as the worm gene
would be so be expressed at the same
time it'll be expressed in the same
organs it'll be expressed at the same
level and I'll respond to stresses in
the same way making the transgenic
involves a couple of steps so the first
thing we do is it will take a wild type
nematode nematode and knock out the
and hopefully we get a phenotype so we
can measure the phenotype on the
knockout then what we do is that we take
a wild-type worm we inject that plasmid
that we generated that has the human
ortholog and we humanize the worm and
what we look for here is a knockout
rescue so we want to see a different
phenotype than we saw on the knockout it
doesn't necessarily replicate the
wild-type phenotype and I'll give you a
couple slides on that in just a minute
to show you what I mean by that but it
needs to be different from the knockout
once you have this generated you can
actually use CRISPR to go and put in the
variants of interest those variants that
you want to test and then you measure
the phenotype in the phenotypes you can
measure on worms or things like movement
and growth and reproduction you can look
at morphology and can look at feeding
what's very interesting about this is
that humanizing that worm is a fairly
lengthy process can take sort of 2-3
months but once you have that humanized
worm Chris bring in those variants of
interest is actually very fast and can
be done in as little as 10 days and this
is actually a really clinically relevant
time frame it's not obviously as fast as
being able to genome sequence the worm
in a day or sorry genome sequence the
the patient in a day but it does
actually can get you to understanding a
very fun known significance in two weeks
we want to explore neurological diseases
as our model because they're fairly
common they affected a large number the
population and they're expensive it's
about 30 billion dollars annually they
can also be difficult the model model or
quantify in vitro so in vitro models do
not always do a good job especially
replicating movement disorders but also
really importantly there's actually 28
after antiepileptic drugs available in
the USA which means we can make a
diagnosis for a kiddo there's possible
treatments for us to give him we're
gonna concentrate on a gene called CAC
and before it's widely expressed in the
brain it mediates the influx of calcium
ions into the into the cell and really
what it does is that it alters the
activation in activation potentials of
the cell so we have four variants we
have a frameshift variant that's
associated with epilepsy and we have one
of the most common
it's the C 104 F which is one of the
first identified variants in this gene
its associated with episodic ataxia in a
french-canadian cohort we also need to
test a benign mutation to make sure that
we can tell pathogenic sfrom benign and
then we have this last mutation which we
call hyper it's actually an insertion
completion so it's a deletion of three
amino acids Hyp an insertion of arginine
and this is a variant of unknown
significance so this was an impatient
that we that we sequenced it has a taxi
and Patos Espina type so the first thing
we do is that we knock this ortholog out
in the worm and that kills the worm they
arrest in the larval stage early larval
stage if we insert the human version of
the gene we actually see that the worms
do not arrest and they grow up and
they're fine and they live happy lives
next thing we want to do is measure some
phenotypes and one of the phenotypes
that's very good at being measured is
the electrophysiology of the feeding
worm so what you see up here is what
they call the n2 this is a wild-type
worm and this trace looks a lot like an
EKG but worms don't have hearts what
we're seeing is the rhythmic feeding of
the worms mouth these two traces are the
same trace just one is longer than the
other so the trace on the left is about
five seconds and the trace on the right
is about twenty seconds so this is what
a normal feeding worm looks like the
knockout obviously is flatlines the
knockout is dead
this is what happens when you put in the
human CAC and b4 we can see that it
doesn't return to wild-type but the worm
is alive but he actually feeds slower
and more sporadically so you can see on
the right that the feeding seems to come
in bursts what we actually think is
happening is that this gene is working
sort of too well and actually sort of
shutting down the neurons and not
letting them fire as quickly as they'd
like to normally when we introduce this
known causative pathogenic mutation what
we see is something kind of interesting
that it's actually returning something
that's a bit more like wild-type and
what we think is happening is that this
mutation is damaging the function of
this gene without turning it off and so
it's allowing the neurons to actually
fire more quickly and then when we look
at the V us what we see is something
that is again very similar to wild-type
and similar to the
on pathogenic mutation this is another
way of visualizing that data so we're
measuring the frequency of eating on the
left and you can see that there's a not
significant difference between the
humanized version and the benign over
there on the right in green and there is
a significant difference in the mean
feeding frequency between the known
pathogenic and RVUs mutation you can see
the same sort of data there on the right
looks a little more dramatic this is a
cumulative distribution plot so it goes
up to a hundred percent and you can see
that our v us and the known pathogenic
mutation clusters very very closely
together whereas the benign mutation
does not you can measure multiple things
in these worms like I said not just
feeding but we could also look at
chemotaxis so what happens there is that
you put the worms in a little petri dish
and you put a chemo attracted to one end
and you give them 30 minutes and see how
long how many of the worms actually get
over there od are 10 which is in the
center there is our negative control so
these worms cannot sense the
chemoattractant and interestingly enough
the human knockin actually replicates
the wild-type phenotype so it does not
greatly affect the worms ability to move
and nor does the pathogenic C 104 F but
interestingly enough the - mutation does
and the worms actually seem to move a
little bit faster with the hyper
mutation so the real question is after
doing all this is hyper pathogenic and
the answer is we still don't really know
it's clusters with pathogenic mutations
but we don't have enough fight data
really to be able to tell whether it's
pathogenic or not and this is work that
we're going to be doing in the next few
months is just really nailing this down
and it's quite important because people
with that C 104 F mutation could be
treated by a drug called Diamox and that
brings us to treatments so like I said
before being able to do this and make
these diagnoses and determine whether
the us's are pathogenic or not is great
but if there's no treatments it's not
especially important to the outcome of
these children there's three kinds of
treatment types starting at the bottom
most people are probably familiar with
drug discovery which is where you take a
huge libraries of tiny molecules and try
to find a brand new drug for a disease
but there's also drug repurposing and
that's where you take a drug that has
had some are possibly a lot of clinical
trials and clinical data might actually
be approved for taking their disease but
we're going to go and repurpose it for a
different disease and then right at the
top is what I call regiment discovery
and this is useful when you have a bunch
of drugs for a particular disease
available but you don't know what the
right one is to give to the child so
having made a worm with a particular
child's mutation in it
you can then use that worm essentially
as a therapeutic avatar right and what
we want to do there is that we want to
take say the twenty-eight antiepileptic
drugs that are available in the US
market and rather than trying each one
on the child until you find something
that works and then stopping there so
you try all twenty-eight in parallel on
the worms find out which ones work the
best and prioritize trying those on the
child
so let's experimental networ matthan all
the children and this is you can also
think of it as female fino mimicking or
Fino copying a drug response so this is
also work that we're going to be doing
in the next few months on CAC and b4 as
well as another gene called KC and q2
which is a common epilepsy gene we are
also working in close conjunction with a
group called caliber and caliber as part
of Scripps research and this is one of
those companies that can do massive
massive high-throughput screening of
hundreds of thousands of molecules but
our interest is actually in repurposing
drugs so they actually have a library of
13 thousand compounds that have some
kind of clinical data already a lot of
them finished stage one clinical trials
and they call this the reframe data set
and what we do here is that we introduce
the mutations into a cell or the cell
can give us some phenotype that could be
read through in a high throughput manner
we then use these massive libraries and
a whole bunch of rather complex robotics
to go and rapidly screen through all
these different drugs
for a drug that can be repurposed to
alleviate the phenotype and for this one
we're actually working on a different
gene called ADC y5 it's a movement
disorder gene and the reason why we like
it is that it's actually a
gain-of-function gene and so we think
generally when we have a drug binding to
a gene or going to or to a protein
rather we're going to be turning that
protein off or turning it down and so
really we're interested in these
gain-of-function mutations as good
targets for initial screens so this is
what we envision the future of precision
pediatric medicine to be like these kids
come in you don't know what's wrong with
over half of them they've already been
sequence because they are sequence in
the first week of life so all we have to
do is pull in their sequence data and
use natural language processing to get
their phenotype and then in five minutes
we can go and prioritize the most
important mutations potentially we have
a definitive diagnosis at that point in
which case we can modify the treatment
and hopefully discharge the child if we
don't because we don't have a good
mutation we can't tell us pathogenic we
can go and rapidly introduce that V us
into a worm model system and in 15 days
hopefully we could have a definitive
diagnosis if there isn't a known
treatment or there's too many treatments
to pick from what we can actually do is
that we can then go and do drug regimen
discovery using that worm that we've
just made to test the V us so I would
like to thank who Stephen Kingsmore was
the CEO of Rady Children's David Dimmock
who's our chief medical officer Shmuel
Chaudhary who's our lab director and
Jenny Freedman many of these patients
I've talked about her hers at NEMA
metrics I'd like to thank Chris Hopkins
who's their CSO as well as Sheila Jaron
who's their vice president of business
development and lastly a caliber I'd
like to thank Nikki Alvarez who's their
associate director of alliances